[موسيقى]
ولعل الدرس الرئيسيه هو ان الاصدقاء
والشركاء ذوي التفكير المتشابه عليهم ان
يتكاتفو كحلفاء عند حدوث مثل هذه الاشياء
ولهذا فاننا فخورون بعلاقاتنا وصداقتنا مع
شركائنا في المنطقه لانه في بعض الاحيان
قد يرفض الناس المبادئ التي تجمعنا مثل
مصالحنا القوميه المشتركه وقدرتنا على منح
شعوبنا حياه مزدهره مسالمه
[موسيقى]
ومن منظور القوات الجويه لابد من السيطره
على المجال الجوي فان فشلت في السيطره على
المجال الجوي سيكون شعبك عرضه لتهديدات
وينسحب ذلك الى قدرتك على ضمان الامن
الغذائي وامل الطاقه وللقوات الجويه دور
مهم لتلعبه في تامين الحياه من الجو
[موسيقى]
هناك خطر دائم في نشر التكنولوجيا بطريقه
تخلو من المسؤوليه كما هو الحال بالنسبه
للمسيرات وغيرها من الاسلحه الاخرى لذا
لدينا شركات في مجال الامن البحري وامن
الحدود وتعد الشركات الامنيه تلك مهمه
للغايه حتى في مجال المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه بحيث نمنع اولئك الذين
يرغبون في الحاق الاذى والضرر ببلداننا
وشعوبنا والبلدان الاخرى ومؤسساتها من
فعلتهم
[موسيقى]